joe biden continues and then he gets
into again the double standards here are
just they are mind-boggling and they're
maddening they're maddening so joe biden
starts talking about the the higher
standards of america that he supposedly
hold and every line here it's like buy
yourself a mirror joe please for the
love of god look in a mirror get your
party a damned mirror sir here we go
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm
are we going to be a nation
will we allow partisan election
officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
are we going to be a nation that lives
not by the light of the truth
but in the shadow
of lies
we cannot allow ourselves to be that
kind of nation okay so i have many many
many questions for the democratic party
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm says joe
biden oh i don't know did your vice
president literally attempt to bail out
rioters a year ago
i
i feel like that happened because i was
there that was a year and a half ago
where were you during the black lives
matter riots joe biden
accepts political violence as a norm
honest to god these people it's like
it's unbelievable
they just they just are going to 1984
your memories out of existence they're
just going to memory whole all this crap
anything bad that happened on their
until now until january 6 did you know
there had been no acceptance of
political violence is a norm did you
know that that didn't exist it was only
trump it wasn't maxine waters saying you
should get up in people's faces or
calling the la rights the la uprising in
1993 1994.
it wasn't democrats
poo-pooing massive riding across the
country in 2020 saying it was mostly
peaceful
it wasn't democrats ignoring the
violence in portland that went on for
months and months and months and when
donald trump sent federal troops in to
try and stop that by protecting federal
buildings they called him a fascist
i remember that stuff because i'm not an
idiot i have a functional brain but some
of these people apparently think that
they can just get away with saying that
the only people who have normal
political violence are people on the
right it's crazy
and it's wild and then he said are we
gonna be a nation where we allow
partisan election officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of i don't
know didn't you guys claim that stacey
abrams was still the governor of georgia
aren't you currently engaged in
redistricting that is far more
beneficial to democrats than republican
redistricting has been to republicans
are we gonna be a nation that lives not
by the light of truth but in the shadow
of lies
okay i have no words for this
from the biden administration which lies
as a matter of routine
they do it over
afghanistan was a was a months-long lie
from don't worry the government won't
collapse it'll be fine to we always knew
the government was going to collapse and
it'll still be fine too we're not
allying in any way with like to al-qaeda
has gone from the country so don't worry
our soldiers are safe so don't worry
we're evacuating people in the most
brilliant evacuation since dunkirk
all they do is lie
shadow of lies my ass
we can't allow ourselves to be that kind
of nation we i'm sorry like that
we too late
you made it happen joe biden you've been
in office since 1831.
and then he gets to the same point it's
kamal harris just takes him longer to
get there his new point is you have to
let us completely rewrite election law
in the united states in order to save
democracy we have to we have to wreck
democracy by federalizing all election
procedure under the auspices of people
joe biden likes
right now
in state after state
new laws are being written
not to protect the vote
but to deny it
not only to suppress the vote but to
subvert it
not to strengthen or protect our
democracy
but because the former president lost
instead of looking at the election
results from 2020 and saying
they need new ideas or better ideas to
win more votes
the former president
and his supporters have decided the only
way for them to win
is to suppress your vote
and subvert our elections
it's wrong
it's undemocratic
and frankly it's unamerican okay i mean
this is the same shtick that this
schmuck was trotting out with regard to
the georgia law which he called a new
form of jim grow so no i don't believe
you i also don't believe that you care
very much about election integrity when
you spend literally a year talking about
how all of the emergency protocols taken
during covid ought to be made the new
normal we ought to be sending absentee
ballots to every household in the nation
we ought to be having democratic
employees engaged in ballot harvesting
going door to door to democratic
registered voters and picking up their
ballots we have to get rid of voter id
everywhere across the country
we ought to federalize all election
procedures that states have no say in it
whatsoever
you know i don't believe that you care
about election integrity i believe that
you want to rig the rules
because you do
yeah i mean the democrats won't even get
together with the republicans to reform
the electoral account act if you are
worried about people quote unquote
stealing federal elections the electoral
count act which led to the vagary of
some people wrongly believing that the
vice president and that the congress had
the ability to throw out state certified
votes
if you believe that that's a problem
then there have been a bunch of
republicans including mainstream
right-wing republicans who have called
for a revision of the electoral account
act to clarify how that procedure works
you know what democrats have done they
said not enough we're not going to do it
we're not gonna revise the electoral
accounts act cause you don't care you
don't care what you really care about is
rigging the rules for yourself
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang